traqué sans relâche par les commandos
israéliens depuis les années 90 cet
homme insaisissable est l'ennemi public
numéro 1 d'Israël Mohamed deif chef des
brigade ezeddin alkassam et tête
pensante de la stratégie militaire du
Hamas palestinien est considéré comme
l'architecte des attaques terroristes du
weekend dernier le samedi 7 octobre cet
homme mystérieux apparaissait tel un
nombre à la télévision palestinienne à
la lumière des crimes répétés contre
notre peuple de l'occupation rampante au
mpris des lois et des résolutions
internationales aujourd'hui la colère
d'alaxa laisse exploser la rage de notre
peuple c'eston du déif l'invité en arabe
aussi surnommé chat aux neuf villes de
Gaza à naplous jusqu'au faubourg de
Jérusalem est son nom est sur toutes les
lèvres nous sommes le peuple de Mohamed
deif Scand ses partisans Palestiniens
mais s'il a jusqu'à présent échappé aux
mains de tsal c'est grâce à son extrême
discrétion un visage sur une photo flou
datant de son incarcération en Israël en
1989 presque rien d'autre ne peut être
trouvé en ligne son surnom d'invité fait
référence au fait qu'il ne reste jamais
au même endroit plus d'une nuit pour
échapper à la vigilance israélienne
d'près le shinpet service israélien de
sécurité intérieure il serait né dans
les années 60 dans un camp de réfugiés
palestinien au sud de Gaza après des
études à l'université islamique de Gaza
où il a côtoyé des membres du Mouvement
égyptien des Frères musulmans il rejoint
le Hamas dont il gravit rapidement les
échelons relat le New York Times mais
c'est après un séjour dans les jaoles
israéliennes en 1989 qut il sort après
16 mois de détention qu'il entre dans la
clandestinité pour n'en plus jamais
ressortir c'est premier fait d'armes
l'organisation dans les années 90 d'une
série d'attentats suicides tuant des
dizaines d'Israéliens qu'il accède aux
plus hautes responsabilités du Hamas en
2002 il n'a qu'une idée en tête
renforcer la force de frappe de
l'organisation islamiste on lui attribue
ainsi la stratégie de l'usage massif des
roquettes ainsi que le dédal de tunnel
creusé sous Gaza où les opérations
terroristes sont pilotées Mohamed deif
aurait jusqu'à présant échapper à H
tentatives d'assassinat il y laisse
cependant un bras et une jambe en 2006
et perd sa femme et ses deux enfants de
7 et 3 mois tués dans un bombardement en
2014 pour autant l'hypothèse de sa mort
ne peut être totalement exclue on ne l'a
jamais vu en vidéo rappelle un ancien
membre des renseignements français or
cacher sa mort permettrait d'entretenir
la légende autour d'un martyre vivant de
la cause
[Musique]
palestinienne